a Russian news agency says that Kurdish
forces have started leaving northern
Syria with Russian troops moving to
enforce a ceasefire along the Turkish
border president Trump has lifted
sanctions against Turkey as a reward
from making a deal with Russia to stop
the fighting he says that he's
fulfilling a campaign promise to get out
of conflicts in the Middle East
Paula Reid is at the White House with
more on this story so Paula good morning
to you does this mean the u.s. is
getting all the way out
oh good morning Gail the president
confirmed that a small number of troops
will remain in Syria to protect key oil
fields from Isis a US official tells CBS
News that plan will involve at least 200
troops but with a small presence the
u.s. is effectively relinquishing
influence in the region and it appears
Russia will now be calling the shots
this was an outcome created by us the
United States and nobody else but the
u.s. was not at the negotiating table
when Russia and Turkey
struck a deal and fighting in northern
Syria let someone else fight over this
long blood-stained sand and while the
president framed his announcement as a
triumph in his effort to press other
nations to take responsibility for
foreign conflicts he failed to mention
that Russia and Turkey will jointly
police a border zone in northern Syria
and push out Kurdish forces who had been
working alongside the u.s. in the fight
against Isis other countries have
stepped forward they want to help and we
think that's great the president appears
willing to cede influence in the region
to Russia saying that the fight against
Isis now falls on others you cannot rely
on Syria Russia or Turkey to protect the
United States against Isis the White
House has tried to downplay how many of
the 10,000 Isis prisoners in Syria may
have escaped there were a few that got
out a small number relatively speaking
and they've been largely recaptured but
that's not what the president's special
envoy for Syria James Jeffery said on
Wednesday we would say that the number
is now over a hundred we do not know
where they are
for now the
has stopped but the Turkish offensive
which was unleashed after the u.s.
withdrew earlier this month cost
hundreds of lives and forced hundreds of
thousands of civilians to flee the
fighting Anthony
Paula thank you